in these poems you'll find the ideas and
teachings of Sufism and Islam expressed
through various kinds of metaphors and
poetic language one of the most common
themes is of course love the
relationship between the lover and
beloved and their wanting to unite with
each other as a metaphor for the
mystical Quest or the theme of wine and
intoxication representing that Divine
love or direct experience of the Divine
and the intoxication that results from
it one of the most famous Sufi poems is
called the song of the read and is in
fact only the opening section of a much
larger poem called the mavi by the
well-renowned Persian sui poet Jalal
Adin roomi here roomi uses the metaphor
of the nay or the Reed flute and how its
beautiful music is a cry of longing to
be returned to its home in the Reed bed
as a reflection of the human longing to
return to Unity in God